she wants to believe it was her that
ended it but basically to me what I
think is usom was like look I want a kid
but a second wife and then my mom still
said yes yes he was like oh you know
what I don't want to have my own kid I
don't want to adopt a kid so if anything
he guilted her into breaking up
that's so true you are right you're
right and I feel like you broke up with
him but it's like he pushed you to do it
and so now he doesn't look as bad you
know because you ended up
he loved her for reasons of what she
could do for him their relationship
didn't make sense to me and his
reasonings didn't make sense you're not
talking about that when she was coming
to me because I really need child
can we talk about the elephant in the
room that nobody wants to talk about
what is the elephant in the room like it
or not
and this is the Optics this is what it
looks like he's more worried about his
reputation in promoting his music
nothing wrong with that okay it makes
him appear like an opportunist Usman do
you agree I see that's not how I can
stay with your body for three years if
really I didn't love her
I cannot stand people accusing me from
America calling me karma when I am not
in the position to even need from
somebody I think Michaela he has his own
purposes and he's beating around the
bush that's what I think uh would you
call him a scammer I can call him a
camera yeah you think he's a scammer
okay he's using you and your love and
he's taking advantage of it I'm scared
to say anything because every time I say
anything y'all just sit up there and
talk about how much I'm defending him
you're damn right I'm gonna defense and
you know why because y'all are laying in
bed with me and him at five six in the
morning
to break up with me
Jamal what do you think
usman's end goal was when he got into a
relationship with your mother
I think his intention of my mom were
like
selfish and narcissistic because it's
like you put her in a position
where obviously you knew she was already
head over heels for you before y'all in
a relationship calling her potential and
all that bull so it's like you knew that
you had her
and you worked her and broke her down
and broke her into pieces which I said I
was gonna have to fix we are not talking
about that I am not the one who cannot
give the child
please stop over talking me
[Music]